it was actually a male strip club that
they shut down for comedy for the first
half you know it was just supposed to be
us performing for these women that were
riled up first thing i got on stage when
they introduced me and this lady was
like pull it out i said hey
hey hey
that's not me i'm not here for that
i'm here to entertain he's a joke
my wife is 100 the fun police like when
i'm when i'm having fun
[Laughter]
everybody wanted to be around because
that was always a good time now will on
the other hand now let me tell you about
this now because i know
first of all you're looking at a new
version of will since the teeth he's
changed
nelson mandela said about that he said
holding a grudge is like drinking poison
and hoping it kills the other person
first of all that's amazing and i'm
pissed off that that i didn't know that
because
that was a real bad moment for me as a
black man because he said
you know everything every black man has
ever seen no no but the way he said it
he's like you know what nelson mandela
said and i was like oh
you were at the laker game last night i
was i was at lakes game court sides
courtside got on the floor might be on
the floor i could touch somebody if i
wanted to
well
it looked like somebody almost touched
you because we here take a look at the
game last night
watch this is you right there
with the lack of improvement almost in
your lap
i understand something uh the reaction
that she saw just now it was an older
chinese woman to my i think she was to
my right yeah uh it looked as if i was
screaming you know probably out of fear
right it wasn't it was it was a chinese
lady watch out
that's what i'm saying but it was here
like i was here with the chinese lady be
careful yeah
nothing to do with me
what is the craziest thing that have
happened to you on stage by far uh
atlantic city it got through a buffalo
wing at me
buffalo wing saucy buffalo wing hit me
right in the cheek
a little bit of the sauce got in my eye
i cried a little bit and i tried to be a
man about it who threw it who threw it
because i'm a man about mine who threw
it guys stood up he was big i was like
i just want us as people to get along
i just got off the stage when you fall
when you fall when you're older it's
different from falling when you're
younger like young were you young and
you fall
right
my life flashed before
[Applause]
i'm not a drug guy like i said i know
what my dad did and and the consequences
of it but a snoop i was like this is a
legendary moment you got to smoke
sure if you get the chance i want to be
able to say to my kids don't do drugs
but if you do do it do it with snoop
you know
that's the thing right
your first time here tell us about
yourself i know you're from philly yes i
am jay uh i'm from philadelphia and uh
i'm a big deal people uh
i don't know
yeah
uh you know jay i'm quite sure you could
tell recently i became a sex symbol yes
you look um
uh besides that modeling gigs are coming
left and right yeah uh baby gap called
uh yeah
just tons of stuff man like right now i
can actually say i'm like a kid in the
candy store i'm enjoying life uh i'm
enjoying where i am i'm enjoying my
comedy career so i said let me come here
on your show to tell people about it
educate y'all tell y'all how i'm doing
you know i'm living life right now it's
going well look at me
but you have an irish name
do i it couldn't be more irish has no
one told you that till now you know i
think my mother just liked the name
let me educate you something black
people
black people are notorious for picking
things that they saw one day and say
that's my baby name
uh i was on tour i brought this leather
jacket and it had a peace sign on the
back of it it was like a rhinestone
peace sign i said you know what i'm
doing the end of my show i'm gonna turn
around show the back of my jacket and
put up a peace sign the crowd gonna go
off i did it nobody said nothing
you have a sweat to the point where you
feel like something's wrong with your
parents like no there was one moment
where i felt like an oil spill like i
remember like we were we were shooting
and i was like no guys quite sure
something's really coming off me right
now hello okay let's just keep rolling
nope there's a there's definitely mud in
my butt right now a hundred percent okay
uh biggest reality check i've had i'm in
vegas right i'm with an athlete friend
of mine and you know you know athletes
make a lot of money so we're there we're
hanging out keep in mind he makes more
money than me jay so i'm trying to keep
up with him sure whatever he does i'm
trying to do it okay so we go to a club
he got a table so i got a table he was
like hey but we're together i said so
what i got money too i want my own table
that's what i told him i'm gonna spend
my own money i'm a man despite my size
right i'm grown okay so
we get there he got bottles i wanted to
get by gotta get bomb yeah you know he
had women come i didn't have no women
but at the time i was with my aunt
it was my aunt's birthday you had your
aunt with me
it was her birthday uh i got the bill
i'm not gonna lie i didn't like it you
have you ever get a bill so high you try
to put it in the light like it's going
to change
it didn't change
nothing changed it was what it was
i had to talk to myself i said i said
kevin you know what just pay the bill go
to your room go to sleep so i go to my
room i go to sleep and here's why i
don't go out with athletes no more the
next morning uh i wake up my friend and
i was with he called me right he was
like kev last night was crazy i said yo
i had a ball he said well guess what
we're gonna do the same thing again
tonight and i was like you know i can't
i can't go twice because the weight of
my bank account is set up like you you
ever
no no
you ever start explaining your financial
situation to people for no reason at all
i said i would go but the way my account
is set up i got i got a checking in the
savings but all the money is in my
savings yeah so i gotta i gotta switch
it to the check-in but it takes three
business days
at this point in time that's all
so i wrote a book i didn't write a book
i wrote a good book
[Applause]
it is getting incredible praise on the
back of your book i'll just read one of
these many many quotes here before
reading this book i was an unemployed
loser sleeping on my mom's couch now i'm
living the life of my dreams all thanks
to kevin hart written by kevin hart
professional athlete yeah yeah and uh
all the other praise comes from kevin
hart somewhat funny comedian kevin hart
award-winning actor and kevin hart life
coach and ladies man yeah those are
different different versions of myself
that gave the book the
i gave the book the just dude how did
you get them to write a blurb for your
book i just had the call of different
versions of myself
yeah i'm very good at going in third
person about myself kevin kevin thinks
this book is genius
me too yeah that was good i want you to
show this picture when all my black
friends say why you don't hang out with
black people no more i want you to show
this
okay cause let me tell you what white
people would have did they would have
helped me up
there white people would have helped me
right there for you are you okay kevin
are you alright come on kevin you gotta
get up get up
the floor is cold kevin get up
you're a married man i know off the
market
calm down ladies
it's all gone ladies you missed the
chance you missed your chance
i had a chance you chose 50 cent
wrong
someone does someone lose their child
i'm sorry all right
you know you know they had to create an
imax just for the two movies that he
made there's two
there's two movies
this is this the dance
for the booty work i'm imagining this is
the left cheek and then this is the
right cheek
a lot of people didn't know uh what i
was doing or what i was going for but
you know the thing about kevin i'm gonna
go third person for a second please the
thing about kevin hart is he's an artist
first and as an artist you need to be
creative
so
he paints it can you be in my video and
i said well i don't just want to be in
it i want to make a mark and i want to
do something that people can remember so
i listened to the song and i thought
about it thought about it thought about
it
as i listened to it the dance came up
with my arms moving from side to side
yes that's right it's basically left
cheek right cheek but my hands are
assimilating what they would do to a
buttocks
we were just having a conversation it
was a random conversation
and you know through the random
conversation
i was like do you watch porn she was
like yeah i watched porn time i was like
get out of here really
hey what like what'd you watch
porn stuff
let me see let me let me see the stuff
you watch
let me see what your stuff is and
she showed me
you know it really hurt me it did a
number
it did a number it did it did a hell of
a number on me because it was so
different from what i am it was so
everything was big i thought everything
tall everybody was tall i was like
i got mad what is this what is this
she's like one i like that stuff
oh my heart matter in terms of the left
cheek or the right cheek definitely
definitely because uh you know if you
with a smaller behind
uh your movement is limited so you know
it's it's definitely a song made for a
bigger buttocks not a smaller one
because uh there's no left cheek right
cheek with a smaller butt it's just
cheek it counts as one i um i didn't
come here to disagree with you but i
have a smaller
butt and i think i do have a left cheek
and the right cheek no you don't
it's a it's a fact that people with
smaller butts don't even have a full
a full butt crack that's a fact
you can look it up you can research it
it's a
half a butt crack because they don't
they don't have enough buttocks to have
a full butt crack he's like oh my god
you got to get brick up and pizza
he's like that's your cherries nigerian
pressure he's like you haven't lived
until you had brick oven pizza
sounds like nipsy russell no no no have
you
you haven't lived until yes
i remember hearing a woman
an older lady who was like she was
cracking crabs
because this is how you crack cracks
looking at me and she's like cracking
the crab i tell a joke and a joke
doesn't work and i remember this lady
just going
oh no
i'm in philadelphia we're filming
untouchable okay um and i had a day off
so i decided to go to the sixers game
james harden is playing in the game and
the whole game the whole first quarter
he's just he's off and i was like you
know why you off because you're in my
city your beard stinks i hate you i was
like i hate your calves i told him i
said i think you got i think you got
butt shots i was saying a bunch of stuff
here and he got mad he said he said
remember all this he said i'm about to
cook you i said you gonna cook me or put
me in a pot because i'm ready to be
cooked
we're talking like he's i don't even
know why he's paying me this much
attention like
at some point i was like james is very
unprofessional on your behalf
you're not even supposed to be talking
to me
james went on to score 55 points and
here's the bad part they beat us by 30.
and with like a minute left he was
dribbling the ball and staying in the
half court and he was just staring at me
and he goes
he goes tell your team what you did to
him and i said
i know dwyane wade he uh he's a friend
of yours yes he was he was talking about
you uh dwyane wade is another good
friend of mine wayne tried to mess up my
life dwayne he didn't no no dwayne
dwayne tried to make me buy a boat i
don't even have a house i said hey man
i told him i told him that i said hey i
don't have a house i don't think this is
a good purchase because you should just
get it right i was like no i would but
the way to my bank account is set up
it's a checking in the savings right but
all the money is in my savings right i
can't i can't transfer it out my savings
that fast it's three business days three
businesses i got a call
i don't want to be on the phone that
long
you were the roast master at the comedy
central yeah justin bieber that taped on
saturday night yeah we just taped it and
how did that go i went a little rough
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah i'm not going live there were
some moments where
i was like justin's gonna cry in the car
there's no way that he's not gonna cry
like you know how you can look at a
person and like they're trying to have a
good time but you can tell there's a
tear
there's one moment where i looked at
justin he's like
it's like a laugh but it's not and i i
kept pointing at him like you better
hold it back boy don't
you don't let the camera see it come
down
he did one knee slap where i think he
covered up a crowd he's like
i was a problem
i was i was the guy that was never
serious uh the most serious moments i
always made the funniest moments i got
along with everybody i was i was
probably the most popular kid in school
because i was funny um and i played
basketball so
that's not nice
what
right now i played varsity basketball
tonight like a little league no no there
was no little league right i was nine
through 12 if you go look it up kevin
hart played varsity you know see i could
have chose basketball but comedy chose
me there was talks there was talks about
me going to the nba i want you to google
zion baptist church it's a league i
played in all right there's a church
league
if you if you go
if y'all go look up my stats in this
church league i averaged 17 6 and 5.
honestly uh mvp of the church league two
years in a row granted it was me and a
bunch of deacons
but but
but you was doing it you saw the talent
that's what i'm saying